the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i will be discussing the recent
official announcement regarding this
year's comic con that's being held in
san diego now for those of you who don't
know hbo will be having their very own
conference for house of the dragon at
san diego's comic con in only a few
weeks from now now that we're only a
little over a month away from the
release of house of the dragon's first
season hbo as well as house of the
dragon's creators will begin to hype up
their show even more than before not
only will house of the dragon
showrunners be there but so will most of
the main actors as well i'm guessing
they will discuss what it was like
making the show as well as what we might
expect to see in the very first season
there's also a very good chance that
this is when they will release their
first official full trailer
for those of you who are wondering san
diego's comic-con is being held from
thursday july the 21st to that sunday
july 24th which is only one month before
the release of house of the dragon i'm
thinking we will get the first full
trailer somewhere around one of those
dates now the good thing is this isn't
even the best news if you ask me what i
find to be very interesting about this
announcement is the fact that george rr
martin will be there as well this will
be the first comic con he has attended
since game of thrones season 4 which was
also the last time he has ever wrote an
episode now if you've seen some of my
older videos then you would know that i
think that was right around when i
believe george rr martin had a falling
out with game of thrones writers david
and dan
as i'm sure most of you already know
after game of thrones season 4 is when
david and dan really started to deviate
from george rr martin's a song of ice
and fire novels this is a big reason why
george stopped writing for the show now
he always said it was so he could focus
on writing the wins of winter but we all
know he wasn't doing that either i think
he left because he could no longer
recognize game of thrones as a
representation or adaptation of his own
work
not only did he stop writing for the
show but he also stopped showing up at
events for the show as well
he hasn't been seen at one of these
conventions ever since
well that's until now
according to these announcements he will
be there with the other creators and
actors from house of the dragon if you
look at house of the dragon's official
social media they've revealed who will
all be there during this year's massive
convention it will be george rr martin
ryan condell and miguel sapochnick who
as you all know are the creators writers
and showrunners for house of the dragon
the actors who will be there are matt
smith patty considine olivia cook emma
darcy steve toussaint eve best and
several others
basically all of house of the dragon's
heaviest hitters will be there
discussing the show now i don't know
about you but i think this would be the
best time to drop that first full
trailer after all this would not be the
first time hbo dropped the new trailer
for game of thrones at san diego's comic
con they did that for game of thrones
season 7 as well
so i do think we very well could get one
during that weekend
now let's get back to george rr martin i
think the fact that he is actually
attending this comic con is a good sign
for us fans of the show i believe it
further shows his confidence in the new
series
it's basically another cosign from the
writer and creator himself
like he said in his not a blog updates
he's already seen nine of the episodes
from the first season and he loves them
he's also went on and on about how great
all of the writers are as well something
he never did for dan and dave in fact
after game of thrones season 4 he
wouldn't even mention their names let
alone be seen sitting next to them
now maybe i'm over excited about all of
this but i really am happy george rr
martin is this heavily involved with the
show i think he made a great decision
getting ryan kondo hired on as a
showrunner because based on everything
i've seen and read ryan is making sure
george knows exactly what's happening
with the show every step of the way now
i'm anxious to see what will be revealed
about the news show during the
convention i will make sure to let you
know if any new interesting information
is revealed remember it is being held
during the weekend of july 21st so make
sure you keep your eyes open for any new
updates i can guarantee there will be
also make sure to look for any of my
other new videos over the next few days
i have a few more updates that i will be
discussing in the following videos
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching this video i hope all of you
have a great day and weekend
i will be seeing you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you